for more on the treatment of covid
patients let's bring in dr richard
lavitan he's an emergency physician at
littleton regional hospital
in new hampshire dr levitan thank you so
much for joining us you know more than
anybody that the daily death tolls are
climbing
you're on the front lines you're about
to start your shift at nine o'clock
paint the picture if you will set the
scene what are you expecting today
well so i'm up in rural new england
about an hour south of canada
and just uh you know people in
major cities may not appreciate the fact
that much of rural america did not see
covet for a long time and in fact the
best areas of the country were vermont
and new hampshire
as well as maine over the summer new
hampshire had
eight cases in one day in august this
week we've had
daily case counts of over 1200
so over the next few weeks in new
hampshire we will see more cases more
hospitalizations
and more deaths likely than we've seen
over the entire pandemic
what has happened why why the why the
big change in the number do you think
well the transmission is just
accelerating
uh it is just accelerating tremendously
you know when we spoke to you back in
april you recommended one of those
oximeters for people
to check their oxygen levels as a matter
of fact after our conversation i went
out and got one myself
now that we have a vaccine does that
change your uh change your advice
you know it is wonderful that the
vaccine is coming i'm supposed to be
vaccinated on saturday
but between now and when the vaccine
takes the wind out of this pandemic
we're looking at 15
maybe 20 million americans getting
infected with covet
and the greatest uh chance
these patients who go on to develop
pneumonia
only about one in 25 patients who you
know get covet develop pneumonia need
hospitalization
but the best chance that patients who
develop covent pneumonia have
is to come into the hospital early
before their oxygen saturation falls
so i recommend that everybody who tests
positive for covid
be monitoring their oxygen levels and be
in touch with their doctor if they see
that number fall
below 93 percent but you know the cdc
website i know you know this doesn't
specifically recommend these oximeters
at home and even some doctors
who when they heard that you were coming
on say they don't think this is a good
idea
they believe it's more accurate to
measure a patient's breath per minute
to determine the oxygen levels what is
your response to that
well you know the best hospitals in the
country uh
are doing this so you know mayo clinic
are doing what uh
occasional or doing what we're doing are
doing pulse
pulse oximetry monitoring of covet
positive patients
so uh you know these oximeters that you
buy at the pharmacy
are reliable uh and you should be
following them and trending them and be
in touch with your doctor but what i'm
telling you is that
the best hospitals in the country are
doing this uh the state of
vermont is only one of 50 states that's
doing it
but of note new york city in the last
two weeks
has now distributed hundreds of
thousands of oximeters
to hospitals so they can monitor every
covet positive patient in new york city
britain nhs england just distributed 200
000 oximeters
so we're seeing a growing movement of
governmental agencies and i hope this
happens in the u.s across
states of monitoring covet positive
patients with oximeters because earlier
detection of illness leads to earlier
treatment
and much better outcomes as we saw with
president trump
and boris johnson i do think what you're
saying
you know makes sense the earlier you
treat it the better the earlier detected
but because
the cdc doesn't recommend it i think
people should check with their doctors
i've heard you say that doctors are
being set up to fail with covet 19. what
do you mean by that
well sadly for my icu colleagues when
you get
patients who have diffuse lung disease
what we call ards
where every area of lung is involved
where oxygen absorption is really
already impaired
where patients lungs have become so
stiff that they can't breathe
those are patients who wind up on
ventilators and and this disease
unfortunately when you get to this
advanced
lung injury we do very poorly with it
there is still
unacceptable high rates of death among
people who get
intubated and hospitalized now it's
important to note that we have reduced
the death rate
uh to one quarter of what it was in new
york city
you know simple things we learned early
on in the pandemic in new york have
really changed practice
that using dexamethasone which is an
inexpensive widely available drug
simple things turning people onto their
stomachs using nasal oxygen instead of
ventilators
we've made tremendous progress but you
do not want to get to the hospital with
very low oxygen and severe lung injury
and so that's what i'm hoping your
listeners hear
all right dr richard leverson thank you
very much